eric what do you got for me buddy
hey what's going on rich can you hear me
good man how you doing all right good
because i was putting on these
headphones to make sure they work um
man i just kind of jumped on here i i
saw you were streaming and i jumped on
and and kind of improvising in here i'm
not sure if we're trying to stay on
topic but um i got something i'm kind of
dealing with here at the moment i
figured i'd get some advice so
um i mean i've never had a problem
getting getting women i mean i've been a
bodybuilder for for many years and i've
always been physically attractive as a
matter of fact they kind of grew in my
last relationship i was with a woman for
10 years and
and seeing my dad the way that the way
that i grew up with that hispanic family
he was always you know my mom left them
he was always running around with
several women that's kind of what i
learned so i messed up my my last
relationship just because i had so many
women kind of throwing themselves at me
and i didn't really know what i wanted
after that relationship i kind of
realized you know what i do want is to
build a family i'm ready for that stage
i'm 37 now um after that separation i
kind of rebuilt my life i went back to
school i became a software engineer so
now i make upwards towards six figures
um i own several properties i've been
really working on on creating wealth
versus income and and i had an accident
i got back in shape um i've done several
things to make my life better
and you know i've read your book i've
watched a lot of your videos and one of
the things on my list of finding wife
has been no children i did that a long
time ago lost two women
never wanted to do it again
and you know i've had my list of things
that i want um a few months ago someone
came into my life i've kind of had him
on the back burner
um because they didn't fill all of the
things in the list she has a daughter
um
she has tattoos even though i'm full of
tattoos it's not really what i want in a
woman
um and i've just kind of had it there on
the back burner but this woman has has
just
stuck with me even though i've kind of
been pushing her away and and i'm i'm
i'm kind of not sure what to do you know
because
you know on one hand she has these
things that i wanted to limit myself on
i mean that i didn't want to have in my
life i don't want to i don't want to
raise another man's child
but um the situations are quite
different i mean her
honestly i mean
she had the baby she's 22 years old so
she's much younger than me which is a
huge plus for me because i want to have
a big family um the first guy that she
was ever with which was one guy is how
she ended up getting pregnant he left
her so the guy's not even in
in her life you know so it's a child
with no man involved
and um and man this woman is willing to
like do anything for me like we just got
off the phone we were having a huge
conversation about her tattoos which you
know something i really like you but
this is this is like a no a deal breaker
for me and like she's willing to go get
all these tattoos removed she's very
well off
her parents left her several properties
so she's
you know she she has a net worth upwards
towards you know close to seven figures
um not that money is everything but but
she's a young girl with with earn the
money at 22 where she could buy so much
real estate and be worth seven years she
kind of um inherited a lot of properties
and she's very very frugal so she does
like she saves all her money which is
kind of how how i am i
i'm very frugal so that's one of the
things that's very important for me you
know not not marrying a spender you know
i'm kind of um all about you know saving
money throwing it out
so what this is really about is you're
looking for rich's blessing to date a
single mommy
um
man
yeah
i guess i guess yeah in a way man yeah
yeah it's kind of you know i i told
myself not to do it
and here i am look man you read my book
i have an entire chapter on dating
single moms so it's not like you're
marching into a slaughterhouse with your
eyes closed you know exactly what you're
walking into
right you've evaluated it you're going
to do what you're going to do anyway
right like my advice to guys is you know
still the same women without kids are
still a far better choice
um
i get that you're 37 or whatever it
happens to be and you want to have kids
and you you know tripped across this
um
unicorn i'm doing anything you know
quotation marks
um that's your call dude but you're
still going to invite all the levels of
complexity into your life raising some
other dude's seat and you're never going
to be able to get rid of that like
that's always going to have to be a part
of your life even if you have five other
kids with her
she's always gonna like that's always
gonna be the six that you didn't sire
that you still raised right so yeah i
mean if you can live with that and
you're cool with that
you know you do you but my advice to
guys still stays the same
yeah
yeah yeah it's definitely been one of
the things that and like you said i read
your book you know i've been down this
path for a long time and i've analyzed
it from other aspects where i'm like
well you know
there's no baby father in the way so
i'll never have to deal with another man
he's well off yeah but it does
yeah but it doesn't change the fact that
you're still raising another man's seat
yeah you know the kid doesn't have your
dna doesn't have your last name it's you
know i tell that to people sometimes and
i think like you know our you know the
red pill community is you know where
people people hear the things that we
say sometimes like
that's so
insensitive for you it's so insensitive
how could you say that it's like it's a
fact a reality it like the kid didn't
come out of my balls it's not mine like
what part of that is confusing to you
right yeah you know people get mad when
you talk about stuff like that
um for me it's very important to create
a bloodline you know it's not just uh
it's not just raising a kid well you're
infringing you're you're infringing your
time resources and everything on
somebody else's bloodline when you raise
another guy's kid so if your bloodline
is what counts
then you have your answer
yeah right yeah i mean i mean does it
does
every situation is different right i
mean understandably well that's what
guys will say right it's complicate life
justify why every situation is different
she's worth seven figures she's got
loads of real estate she's willing to
take the tattoos off she's totally in my
frame she's sweet [ __ ]
how long you've been dating her for
man um
it's been about eight months and even
then like dating is are you saying
what was that are you still spinning
plates you're still seeing some other
women
yeah very v very rarely even though i
have women throw themselves at me all
the time i have so many goals right now
like i work seven days a week right now
i have all of these goals to create
wealth
she comes to visit me like she gives me
all this time that nobody else will give
me like dude
out there there's loads of women out
there that that tick off all the same
boxes but don't bring some other
[ __ ] kid you know until yeah
i'm just saying
i'm just saying right
but i mean if you live in a limited you
know demographic where there's not a lot
of options and your time is limited and
you've spun plates and this is the cream
that's roasted the top and that's a you
know like that's a choice that you're
willing to make uh guys like you're
always gonna make concessions when it
comes to
picking mother stock right it's it's
like yeah what is it gonna be like is
like you know so you know jaren just put
it in here i was just about to say it
you know so the single mom is the
easiest option basically is what you're
saying right
they're always easy at first they're
always you know simple to deal with date
her for a couple years and see what
she's made of see if you really want to
be with her after after two years see if
you want to make her a mother of your
five kids and your legacy after a couple
years of danger dealing with her kid
taking vacations with a kid you know
doing family events with her and the
kids sort of thing
see if you still want to be with her
then
right my advice to you is is just to
slow down and
really you know get your head wrapped
around if this is oh i'm like i'm like a
snail paste believe me i'm like
i'm like a snail paste it's it's i've
even struggled to color my girlfriend
but this girl
just sticks by me man and and it's just
been one of those things where i'm like
huh kind of well
eric eric you know with all due respect
that's very easy to do for the first
eight 12 14 months
like apply some stress to the
relationship
try tr
okay try this try to discipline her kid
like you've met her kid
try to discipline her kid see if she
lets you discipline the kid when it
misbehaves see if the kid pulls some
[ __ ] like you're not my father
well the kid is actually um she just
turned two but that's that's kind of
what what has left me here she wants me
to take that role she has very
conservative roles where she's like
listen i have all of this money i don't
even know what to do with it okay i need
something to come and she had an
opportunity to discipline a kid's bad
behavior
yeah and that's that's kind of why she
wants me to come in she kind of wants me
to come in she believes that a a baby
needs a male leader a male role to kind
of event and she's like that submissive
woman that that that a lot of people are
looking for and i mean
it's it's just it's just one of those
things i haven't like she wants me to
discipline the child she wants me to
adopt the child and then give me a bunch
of other kids dude there's no father
around that's why she wants you to adopt
a child
yeah
listen man you know my stand on it
you've read my book there's an entire
chapter on dealing with single moms um
you know read it again read it three
times if you need to
like you know what you're dealing with
here right so just
do whatever it is that you want you're
gonna do what you want anyway
but just
walk into the slaughterhouse that you're
marching into with your eyes wide open
she yes you're painting her to be a much
better option because she doesn't have
debt she doesn't have any financial
issues she's conservative she's in your
frame blah blah blah blah she wants to
have more kids all sort of stuff i get
it i get it i totally get it but just
completely understand what it is that
you're marching into and very good point
over here is the wealthy broke man says
if she's traditional she won't have any
tats
yeah that was that that was our our one
our conversation if she was traditional
she wouldn't have any tats if she was
traditional she wouldn't have some other
[ __ ] kid in tow
let's just be honest right yeah yeah
yeah i mean there's a story behind that
it was a year of course fine fine but
but i mean like you're putting her up on
a pedestal and you're trying to you know
dismiss
certain negative traits that she's
bringing along by highlighting and
spotlighting she owns real estate and
she's worth seven figures and blah blah
and she's really submissive and she's in
my frame i got it right but you can't
dismiss the fact that she's got tattoos
you can't just you know dismiss the fact
that
i can't i can't stand them
i can't stand the damn time
i'm putting a tattoos here well again
this is like people that are watching
right now and i'm turning the camera to
talk to you people because these [ __ ]
people always argue with me
we have a guy on right now that's
completely tatted up that doesn't want
anything to do with a chick with tattoos
men and women are not the same
okay we have different
wants do you understand what i'm saying
this is like one of the examples that
i'm showing you here and now sort of
thing
anyway you get the point eric yeah thank
you for your time and i appreciate you
thanks all right see ya peace
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you